my name is Susanna Kaelin I'm 21 years
old and Here I am with my dream job at
the New York Post gross why are you
smiling this early in the morning it's a
natural assessment you look ridiculous
you're gonna interview that creepy
Center you'll have that Thursday night I
know I will cause I can always count on
you
I had my whole life in front of me and I
had absolutely no idea what was waiting
for me
[Applause]
you're very very late you gotta get your
ass in here you're gonna miss the 10
o'clock I feel sick no my stomach hurts
and my bands numb I've never fought
we've tested Susana for every infectious
disease all of the results are negative
woman it's a bomb in this together her
EEG is completely normal for MRI is
normal her illogical exam is normal it's
all normal
her condition continues to regress manic
behavior annoy us each of them is giving
us a different diagnosis when I say
bipolar next - a schizophrenic - then
they're saying psychotic we should look
at hospitals that are better equipped to
deal with distance we shouldn't all of
us you would find the answer
your hands tell me what is wrong you
must be the famous Susana that's I know
she's still in there she's just trapped
[Music]
I promise you're going to do everything
you can to find you time is of the
essence
[Music]
you